Me faites pas ça !
Le train de 8h05 pour Manhattan
entre en gare.
Le relais 4 X 100,
c'était notre course.
Quatre gars, un million
de molécules d'adrénaline,
huit jambes,
et un seul coeur.
Chacun donnait tout ce
qu'il avait pour passer le témoin.
Ce jour-là, le dernier coureur
avait dû rattraper les précieuses
secondes perdues en nous
laissant distraire par Lisa Fentner,
avec sa poitrine de rêve
et ses bas résille.
Il ne nous en a pas tenu rigueur.
ll savait que nous comptions sur lui.
Et il a terminé.
Peu importe le retard accumulé,
nous l'avions.
Nous avions le finisseur.
Tout le monde en voiture !
Attention à la marche.
Je pige pas,
il était prêt d'arriver.
Ses grolles...
Il avait des pompes de ville.
T'as vu comment il courait,
il n'a pas perdu la forme.
Il a raté son train,
il sera en retard à son boulot.
Le reste, les chaussures, la condition
physique, n'ont pas d'importance.
T'étonne pas si personne
ne t'invite en soirée.
C'est quoi ton problème avec lui ?
Je suis réaliste.
Non, t'es juste jaloux,
il a encore la hargne et toi...
t'enlèves les amygdales.
En orthopédie, on ne s'occupe pas
d'amygdales.
Il a renoncé.
Les gens renoncent.
Tu ne devrais pas manger
aussi gras.
C'est à cause de ses chaussures.
Si tu le vois comme ça.
Je sais ce que j'ai vu.
Il n'a pas renoncé.
Tu as oublié la réunion.
On a hérité du budget Luxor,
lis ça si tu as un moment.
Luxor, pas de problème.
Tu n'en a rien à foutre.
Comment ça ?
De ce qu'on fait, de ton travail,
de l'assurance maritime.
Tu sais Bertie,
quand tu grandis à Long Island,
tu es attiré par
tout ce qui est maritime.
On ne m'avait pas dit que ce boulot
n'avait aucun rapport avec la mer,
donc me voilà échoué
au 10ème étage d'une tour.
Tu es la seule personne
qui fume encore !
Ça ne me dérange pas.
Tu sais ce qui fait
la grandeur de ce pays ?
Broadway et
ses comédies musicales.
J'y allais souvent quand
j'étais jeune avec mes parents.
Ces chansons ont quelque chose,
du coeur, de l'espoir...
Rassure-toi Bertie,
je préfère les filles.
Mais je dois avouer que ton regard
bleu azur me trouble...
D'abord, c'est Bert.
Éteins ça, achète un malabar
et va bosser.
J'ai deux ans de moins que toi,
je suis arrivé après toi
et j'ai déjà eu
deux promotions.
Tu sais pourquoi ?
Tu te laisses aller.
Au cas où tu pensais avoir la classe,
t'es à côté.
Vous feriez mieux
de faire de l'exercice.
Je peux faire
les deux en même temps.
Un voyageur qui somnole a
des chances de rater son arrêt.
La côte Est
n'est pas ma destination.
Ce soir, c'est hockey
et je mange avec ma mère.
Qu'est que c'est ?
Je vois le président,
un alignement de tribunes,
des fleurs, ça me semble être...
Le Madison Square Garden,
ce soir.
Deux places, pour toi et ta mère,
juste derrière la vitre.
Je ne pouvais pas oublier la femme
la plus importante de ma vie.
Vous êtes génial,
mais pas très malin.
Je vous remercie de me le rappeler.
Fais pas cette tête, Bertie !
C'est la fête !
Je suis enfin rentré à la maison,
mon ange.
Je t'adore...j'adore mon travail...
et j'adore être ton mari!
Non merci.
Tu as oublié ?
D'accord !
Je comprends, tu es très occupée.
Joyeux anniversaire de mariage !
Tu veux qu'on le fête
dans la chambre d'amis ?
Te souviens-tu à quoi elle était
destinée ?
La chambre d'enfants !
On n'est même pas fichus
de dresser notre chien.
Je plaisante... en fait,
je me sens prêt.
Quand je te regarde, je me dis
que la vie est un vrai cadeau...
et qu'il ne faut pas avoir peur
de s'engager.
J'ai reçu une offre d'emploi
du musée de Boston.
Je peux commencer cet automne.
Comme conservatrice.
J'ai besoin de m'éloigner de toi
pour réussir ma carrière.
Dis-moi qui c'est ?
Tu l'as rencontré à ton boulot ?
C'est un amateur d'art ?
Tu ne me quittes pas pour rien !
Qui est-ce ?
Très bien, si tu préfères le savoir,
il y a quelqu'un d'autre.
Et c'est lui qui me conforte
dans ma décision.
Tu as eu un moment d'égarement,
je peux comprendre.
Je pense qu'il serait plus simple
que je parte dès maintenant.
Non, non écoute!
C'est moi qui vais
m'éloigner quelque temps.
Ça te permettra de respirer...
et de réaliser qu'on ne peut pas
vivre l'un sans l'autre.
C'était il y a 15 jours...
Quoi ?
notre anniversaire.
Il était comment au téléphone ?
Il avait l'air triste ?
Mais j'en sais rien !
Comment tu peux bouffer ça ?
J'ai les crocs.
Tout fout le camp, et tu bouffes !
Ils font juste un break.
Ils ont besoin d'un break ?
Je m'inquiète pour lui.
Tu te fais du mouron pour rien.
Comment est-ce que...
C'est sympa d'être venus !
On allait pas te laisser seul.
C'est pas notre genre.
Ce sont des amis...
Artie, petit génie de
littérature contemporaine.
En fait, j'écris pour une revue
automobile.
Kipp, un musicien grandiose.
Je fais des jingles.
"Souriez... vous êtes filmés..."
Wacka Wacka
Ils sont trop modestes.
Et je vous présente...
Caroline...
actuellement dans l'arbitrage,
mais je ne sais pas du tout
ce que c'est !
C'est sans intérêt.
Je réserve une table ?
Bonne idée.
Je reviens tout de suite.
Qui est-ce ?
La copine de notre pote.
Ce n'est pas ma copine, c'est...
une bombe sexuelle.
Il est marié !
Il est séparé.
C'est provisoire.
Elle a juste besoin de réfléchir.
Pourquoi ?
Pour comprendre qu'elle m'aime
plus que ce mec.
Quel mec ?
Phoebe te trompe ?
Tu plaisantes ?
Ça m'a fait un sacré choc !
Venez, la table doit être prête.
Mais c'est qui ?
A votre service, monsieur.
La même chose,
tu reprends un double ?
Volontiers.
Vous tenez bien l'alcool !
Vous avez l'air parfaitement...
Parfaite !
Vraiment ?
Messieurs ?
Rien, merci.
Nous devons partir.
Quoi ?
Le train n'attend pas !
Il n'est pas tard !
Il faut y aller.
Reprenez un verre !
On n'a pas le temps.
Enchanté.
Si tu as besoin,
tu me téléphones !
À bientôt.
Caroline, c'est bien Caroline ?
Ce n'est pas Carrie, ou Dave.
Caroline, je ne sais pas
comment exprimer mon idée,
tu connais Don Quichotte?
Il se faisait passer pour
un chevalier héroïque,
scintillant dans son armure,
alors qu'il se battait contre
des moulins à vent.
Comment pourrais-je dire ?
En fait, je suis...
Marié.
Et fidèle depuis des années.
Exact ?
Donc, aucun risque.
Pardon ?
Sexuellement.
En ce sens,
je suppose
que je suis sans risque.
Le problème, c'est que j'aime
toujours ma femme.
Bien que nous soyons
provisoirement...
je ne pourrais pas avoir une
relation, comment dire...
Sérieuse.
Exactement.
Où est le problème ?
Je suis rentré !
Correction, je suis là.
Il faut qu'on parle.
Quel con !
Je suis désolé.
Je voulais pas te réveiller.
Bon sang !
Mike ?
Est-ce que ça va ?
Oui, tout va bien.
J'ai perdu mes clefs de voiture.
T'as qu'à rester dormir ici.
Oh non, en fait,
je voulais emprunter ta caisse.
Mon break est en révision.
Je pensais pas au break.
Quoi ?
Je te la ramène demain.
C'était pas prémédité.
J'ai promis une virée à Caroline,
tu te souviens ?
On doit aller à Ellis Island
demain à l'aube.
Pourquoi ?
J'en sais rien.
Peut-être parce qu'elle est
ma maîtresse.
Tu as couché avec elle ?
Juste en copains.
J'ai pensé à
faire autre chose avec elle,
car je suis pas très fier.
Elle est sympa.
C'est une bonne idée de faire
un peu de tourisme.
Et Phoebe ?
Elle ne se gêne pas.
Le fait est qu'elle m'a quitté.
En tous cas,
j'ai besoin d'une caisse.
C'est un petit bijou,
je ne la conduis jamais.
C'est une bagnole.
T'entends pas cette puissante
cylindrée te crier...
Conduis-moi !
Doucement.
Tu es un prince, mon ami.
Disparais !
Reste pas en première !
Change de vitesse,
change de vitesse !
Le docteur Shepperd est demandé
en salle de réveil .
Salut, pacha !
A ton rétablissement.
Merci.
Je me suis senti Tout-Puissant,
j'ai ignoré la loi !
Tu t'en tires bien.
T'étais sur les terres de Felder.
Donc, les dommages...
Je ne parlais pas de cette loi.
Tout corps en mouvement
garde sa vitesse
si une force d'inertie ne l'arrête.
Une voiture heurtant un arbre
est automatiquement stoppée.
Oui, c'est sûr.
Tu veux une part de pizza ?
Je n'ai pas faim.
Tu devrais manger.
Une côte cassée,
Tu t'en sors mieux que ma voiture !
Viens là.
Je te promets de te la réparer,
quelque soit le prix.
T'en fais pas pour ça.
Pense à toi.
Non, j'y tiens.
Où t'as eu ça ?
C'est une infirmière.
Blanchisserie, j'écoute ?
T'es dingue de lui avoir
apporté ça !
C'est mieux que la bouffe de l'hosto.
Le champagne !
T'es irresponsable !
Qui a prêté sa caisse
à un mec bourré ?
Je le savais pas.
Quand il débarque chez toi
à 2 heures du mat ?
Te voilà !
Il est dans cette chambre,
si ça t'intéresse.
Tu verrais ma caisse !
Comment j'ai galéré pour
trouver une Mustang des années 60 !
Et j'ai des relations,
ça m'aide à trouver les occases !
Pourquoi t'es venu ?
Pour prendre tes messages ?
On le prend, merci.
On a un rendez-vous.
A 16 h 30, jeudi.
C'est la seule date possible.
Qui va y aller?
Ceux qui ne veulent pas
qu'il se tue la prochaine fois.
Essaie de venir.
Francis Scott Fitzgerald
Edgar Allan Poe
Jim Thorpe
Le général Grant
Isadora Duncan, Edith Piaf,
arrêtez-moi si vous êtes
en désaccord,
toutes ces personnalités étaient
alcooliques comme votre ami.
Ils étaient actifs,
ils ont connu le succès,
et fait souffrir leurs proches.
Leurs amis ont tenté de les aider,
mais il leur manquait la clef,
la technique.
Je suis musicien, et je connais.
On coince le type, et on lui fout
la honte en l'insultant.
Méthode infaillible.
Ces interventions sont généralement
mal vécues.
Le but n'est pas
de rabaisser votre ami,
mais de l'inciter à changer,
pour ne pas risquer de perdre
votre amitié.
Je reste son ami.
Moi aussi.
Taisez-vous.
Quel est le processus ?
Vous devrez inventer une ruse,
pour endormir sa méfiance.
Je voudrais bien qu'on aille
faire un tri dans le grenier.
Faites en sorte
qu'il ne puisse pas refuser.
Samedi midi ?
Tu me manques terriblement.
Veux-tu dîner ?
Avec toi ? J'en serais ravi !
La famille joue un rôle essentiel.
Ses parents devront participer.
Tu te rends compte, on ne l'a
pas vu depuis le printemps !
Ce crétin s'est planté parce qu'il
avait picolé. T'as pas entendu ?
J'ai très bien entendu.
On est invités à une petite fête.
Je me demande parfois
sur quelle planète tu vis.
Mousseline... ou soie ?
Il faut l'aider aussi au travail.
J'ai mille fois mieux à faire
un samedi !
C'est quoi ça ?
Racines d'aubépine.
Ça pue le chat crevé !
Il faut lui pointer ses défauts.
Ça doit être rudement bon,
c'est de l'aubépine ?
Vous avez mentionné une amie.
Elle pourrait aussi être utile.
Sa femme est au courant
de notre aventure ?
Ça m'a échappé.
Est-ce qu'il sait qu'elle sait ?
Pas encore.
Je vous conseille de noter
ce que vous avez à lui dire.
C'est très efficace. Soyez brefs.
Quelques phrases suffisent.
Deux secondes !
Regarde comme elle est mince !
Bonjour Phoebe.
Venez !
Après toi.
Je serai présent à la réunion.
J'exposerai les buts,
et j'orienterai les débats.
Qu'est-ce qu'il fout ?
Je suis sûr qu'il va venir.
Tu lui as laissé un message ?
S'il s'était endormi ?
On en a fait des opérations
militaires.
A Grenade.
S'il avait un problème,
il m'en aurait parlé.
Au Panama.
Avec ça, je vais faire mouche.
C'est à la fois compatissant
et caustique.
On ne pourrait pas le bipper ?
On avait une mission,
on s'en acquittait.
Où est sa blonde ?
Tu l'as convaincue de venir ?
Elle n'était pas chaude.
Ta petite amie va venir ?
C'est sérieux, vous deux ?
On pourrait
pousser un peu la clim ?
Ta mère va bien ? Quelle femme
adorable ! Et sa chevelure !
Elle a vraiment des cheveux
magnifiques !
Elle est décédée.
Je suis désolée !
Je ne savais pas.
J'étais en 3ème,
vous êtes venue à l'enterrement.
Tu es sûr ?
Ça alors !
Excuse-moi, mais...
ton père est toujours en vie ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on s'en fout !
Je me souviens bien de lui.
Quel grand homme !
Et sa tarte aux pêches pour le
concours de pâtisserie !
Il était le seul homme à concourir.
Ferme ton clapet !
Il faut faire court,
mais j'ai un milliard d'idées,
je préfère suivre mon instinct.
Oh, mon Dieu !
Le voilà !
Je vous l'avais dit.
Non, pas le toubib !
C'est la voiture de Mikey !
C'est carrément surréaliste !
Michael est là !
On fait quoi ?
Si on se cachait ?
Salut.
Surprise !
Nous sommes tous réunis
pour te venir en aide,
avec l'aide d'un spécialiste
qui en principe,
ne va pas tarder.
Après cet accident stupide,
on a pensé...
mais c'est pas à cause
de la voiture !
On a pris des notes,
on va te les lire à haute voix.
On nous a fait venir de Phoenix.
Une fois, t'as fait un tennis elbow,
et maintenant çà !
J'étais sûre qu'ils s'étaient trompés.
Tu as l'air en pleine forme, chéri.
En parfaite santé.
Elle a raison,
écoute pas leurs conneries.
Du thé ?
Bravo les garçons, tout est foiré !
Pas de panique,
puisqu'on est là, on va rester.
On va jouer au golf,
passer un bon week-end en famille.
Il revient !
C'est bon signe, non ?
C'est mieux que de se tirer.
Je peux te voir un instant ?
On allait soit disant vider
le grenier !
Je voulais être gentil,
et j'espérais qu'on ferait l'amour !
Tu as failli te tuer !
Tout le monde boit un coup
de temps en temps, où est le mal ?
C'est pour ça que tu ne veux
plus de moi ?
Ç'est bien ça ?
Parce que toi et ton nouveau mec,
vous sirotez des jus de fruits
à l'apéro ?
Tu m'as viré pour un...
Salut, merci d'être venue.
Excusez-nous,
on ne fait que passer !
Nous devions inviter
tous tes proches.
Pourquoi le docteur n'est-il pas là ?
Il est en route,
on contrôle la situation.
Sur quelle galaxie ?
Je suis charmée de vous connaître,
j'ai connu Artie tout gosse.
Il n'était pas un grand séducteur,
mais je vois qu'il a changé.
Quelqu'un pourrait répondre ?
J'y vais.
C'est un choix aberrant
de l'avoir invitée !
Question alcool,
elle m'envoie carrément au tapis !
C'est pas grave.
Quoi ?
Tu es libre à présent.
Je ne veux pas de cette liberté.
Ce n'était qu'une aventure
sans lendemain.
Bon sang !
Qu'est-ce que je peux faire
pour me racheter ?
Viens à la réunion.
Je ne peux pas.
Si, tu peux !
Je n'ai pas envie que tu aies
un autre accident !
Je suis désolé.
Va à la réunion.
Allez, va.
J'ai un patient sous sédatif.
Je sais que la situation est
problématique.
J'ai une autre méthode.
Salut.
Bienvenue chez les dingues.
Le vol a été bon ?
Ta mère est détraquée.
Elle a pris toute sa garde robe.
T'es un poivrot, il paraît ?
J'ai volé les cacahuètes que tu aimes,
pendant l'absence des hôtesses.
Merci, maman.
Je ne suis pas un poivrot, papa.
Mais je semble être le seul
à le penser.
Ah, te voilà !
J'aurais pas cru que tu m'en
voudrais autant pour de la tôle !
Le docteur a un empêchement.
Un de ses patients a tenté
de se suicider.
Il essaie de le stabiliser.
Il propose de commencer sans lui,
de lire nos notes,
et il pourra peut-être nous
rejoindre plus tard... "peut-être" !
Et c'est dans ce type que...
que vous mettiez votre confiance ?
Un spécialiste des candidats
à la pendaison ?
C'était des somnifères, je crois.
Vous l'avez trouvé
dans les pages jaunes ?
Le docteur Trent est très réputé.
Et son hôpital est renommé.
Il a beaucoup de patients.
Des suicidaires en puissance ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Je ne sais pas pour vous,
mais moi, j'ai la dalle.
J'ai des surgelés.
On se paie un resto.
Mes parents n'ont pas fait
tout ce trajet pour des surgelés.
Eh bien ?
J'ai une bonne adresse. Venez !
J'adore cet endroit !
C'est pourquoi je garde
ma carte de club.
On se contente de déjeuner,
ou on fait la réunion ?
On peut la faire ici.
Ils font les mariages,
les bar mitzvahs,
tous les grands événements.
Vous désirez un apéritif ?
Un whisky sec.
Non, plutôt une eau minérale !
Monsieur ?
Moi aussi, de l'eau.
Oui, également.
Allons...
ne vous privez surtout pas
pour moi !
Tu veux un verre de Chablis ?
Excellente idée.
Evelyn !
Quoi ?
Je prendrai une vodka.
Qui êtes-vous, au juste ?
Caroline est une amie à moi.
Ce n'est pas la petite amie
de Artie ?
Donnez-moi un gin tonic !
Qu'entends-tu par amie ?
Ça ne nous regarde pas.
Les choses doivent être claires.
Et rien n'est clair ici !
Caroline est une relation.
Et Phoebe, de son côté...
Les relations humaines,
c'est d'un compliqué !
Je vous vois bien en entraîneuse
personnelle de Michael.
Je sais combien tu tiens
à garder la forme.
Ma présence ici est inutile.
Je vous raccompagne, si je peux
faire mon laïus en premier.
Non, vous devez rester. Tout le
monde doit rester. C'est essentiel.
Pourrais-je avoir un verre de vin ?
Qu'est-ce qui t'arrive ?
Quoi ?
Tu ne bois jamais !
Bien sûr que si !
Dans les grandes occasions.
Donnez-moi un soda light.
Personne n'y voit d'inconvénient ?
Aujourd'hui, tu es autorisé à boire
si tu en as envie.
Tais-toi donc !
C'est ce que le toubib m'a dit
au téléphone.
On doit se comporter normalement.
Tu n'as pas à l'encourager !
T'inquiète pas.
Je peux me contrôler.
On s'y prend mal.
Certainement.
Je suis là, bien sagement assis,
à essayer de comprendre votre
point de vue.
Je me suis planté contre un arbre,
et vous appelez un crétin de psy
pour monter ce plan grotesque.
Je ne veux pas vous décourager,
mais je crois que vous avez faux !
Il paraît que c'est un appel à l'aide.
Moi qui croyais que c'était
un accident !
Il nous a dit que tu pourrais être
sur la défensive.
Qu'est-ce que je ne suis pas censé
faire ? J'aimerais être original !
Il a dit que ce serait pas facile.
Le but de cette opération,
est que tu acceptes d'être aidé.
Si tu refuses, nous devrons tous
te tourner le dos.
C'est pas une plaisanterie.
C'est pas un déjeuner au club !
Parfait !
Je sais à quoi m'en tenir.
C'est bien de connaître les règles.
On déjeune ?
Le docteur a conseillé de
commencer sans lui.
C'est maintenant ou jamais.
Stuart dirigera le débat.
En fait, il était le seul volontaire.
Tu connais cette chanson ?
Non, mais toi, oui.
"Bien avant de te connaître,
bien avant de te rencontrer,
je savais que je te trouverais,
un jour, quelque part."
Je t'ai trouvée !
Si on dansait ?
Une petite danse, et ensuite
je suis à vous !
Ils nous attendent.
On ne peut pas commencer sans toi.
C'est un vrai cauchemar, ce repas.
Et tu es l'invité d'honneur.
Allons-y.
Je suis sûr de l'avoir pris.
T'as qu'à réciter.
De mémoire ?
Oui.
J'avais noté des détails,
j'ai besoin de ma fiche !
T'as qu'à passer ton tour.
Non, chacun doit s'exprimer.
Je commence.
Ce n'est pas ton tour.
Peu importe.
C'est pas ton tour !
Je m'en fiche !
Il faut respecter l'ordre.
Ça m'est égal, j'y vais.
On doit parler en respectant le sens
des aiguilles d'une montre.
Un verre de Chablis, je vous prie.
C'est bon; j'y vais !
Basiquement, ça donnait un truc
du genre,
tu bâcles ton travail.
T'es un incapable.
C'est tout ?
Je m'attendais à une encyclopédie.
J'avais noté les grandes lignes.
Quand je participais à des débats,
j'étais vraiment bon pour exposer
le thème général,
mais dans le développement
de l'idée,
j'avais comme une déconnection,
entre mon cerveau et ma bouche.
C'était le trou noir.
Tout devenait confus.
Excuse-moi.
Oui.
Il ne s'agit pas de tes problèmes.
Je suis désolé.
On a un cas à régler.
Il est nettement plus atteint que lui.
Est-ce qu'il a le droit
de parler comme ça ?
Non, non.
- Quel merdier !
- On ne fait aucun dialogue,
on ne converse pas.
Quelle merde !
Chacun fait son speech, et c'est tout.
Je pense que tu bois,
car tu es piégé par la conception
occidentale de la réussite,
où il faut gravir tous les échelons,
pour justifier son existence.
Excusez-moi, mademoiselle,
vous n'êtes pas de chez nous,
mais la réussite est une valeur
fondamentale dans ce pays.
J'aime ce pays plus encore
que vous même,
je peux réciter la Constitution
et ses amendements,
dans l'ordre croissant ou décroissant,
à votre convenance.
C'est simple, tu es un chauffard.
T'as bousillé ma caisse.
Tu as toujours fait ma fierté.
Elle tenait une grande place
dans ma vie.
Et ça ne changera jamais.
T'es un incapable.
Pour moi, on fait trop de cas
de la sobriété.
Tu ne sais pas boire.
L'écoute pas !
T'es irresponsable.
T'es le Roi, mec !
T'es un danger pour toi,
Surtout change rien !
et la société !
J'ai rien à ajouter.
Normal, après 4 cocktails.
Je t'emmerde !
Rassieds-toi !
Tu bâcles ton boulot.
Cependant, tu ne devrais pas boire
au volant.
Je comprends pas.
Le pire, c'est de s'autodétruire.
Point final.
Souviens-toi...
Pas la peine de l'écrire !
T'as été chef de classe.
Maman !
Oui, chéri ?
Ne me fais pas ça !
Ne fais pas de commentaires
avant que ce soit fini.
Ne sois pas si modeste.
Il a eu un petit accident
à son 1er jour d'école.
Peut-être l'anxiété, ou les pruneaux
que j'ajoutais à ses céréales ?
J'ai dû lui rapporter un nouveau
petit pantalon propre.
Et comme il s'était montré...
tellement courageux,
sa maîtresse l'a nommé
chef de classe.
Il a imposé silence à tous ces petits
monstres qui se moquaient de lui,
en le traitant de vilains noms,
comme "pue du cul".
Il les a tous fait mettre en rang,
pour aller à la cantine,
en séparant les demi pensionnaires,
des autres.
Il les a obligés à rester debout, et...
Une fois, tu m'as emmenée
dans un restaurant.
Ils n'avaient pas encore
leur licence d'alcool.
Tu as fait de ton mieux.
Mais tout au long du repas,
tu comptais les secondes,
pour pouvoir partir,
et prendre un verre ailleurs.
Ou plusieurs.
Et c'est peu de dire,
que ça m'a fait mal.
Le seul fait qu'on soit ensemble
ne te suffisait pas pour être bien.
La séance est levée ?
Attends !
J'ai quelque chose à ajouter.
Ecartez-vous !
Je sais quoi faire pour le sauver !
C'est une crise d'asthme.
Du calme !
Aide-moi, tu veux ?
Ses bras au-dessus de sa tête !
Respire profondément !
Calme-toi !
Je voulais te dire...
Non, reste calme !
Détends-toi !
J'aime ta femme !
Seigneur !
C'est la seule qui me comprenne.
Alors c'est lui ?
C'est ton amant ?
C'est absurde !
Je me casse !
J'aime ta femme.
Je l'aime !
Mon gâteau !
Je m'étais jamais fait virer
de nulle part !
Quand il dormait chez nous,
je lui faisais des gaufres !
Je vais le tuer !
Non, arrête ! C'est bon !
Tu l'as envoyé à l'hôpital !
T'as bien fait !
Où vous allez ?
C'est vrai qu'il se tape ta femme ?
C'est bon !
Lâche-moi !
Mais où tu vas ?
Mike !
Ouais, t'es furax !
Il nous déteste.
Je sais.
Bordel !
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
Moi, je rentre,
je vous laisse la bouteille ?
Qu'est-ce qui vous a pris, à tous ?
C'est Stuart.
- Une idée à la con !
- Conneries !
C'est vrai.
Qui a invité Caroline ?
Ils m'ont désigné.
Et mes parents ?
Je suis plus un gamin !
Elle vous a plu,
l'histoire de ma mère ?
Merde !
Ma femme et mon pote !
merde !
Vous saviez qu'ils étaient maqués ?
- Non.
- Non, je te jure !
Calme-toi, vieux !
Ecoute-moi,
On n'est pas toujours fidèles,
tu piges,
même ma femme m'a trompé,
oui, Marjorie !
C'est pas possible !
On est allé à Charleston,
pour un anniversaire.
Il y avait ce cousin,
ils sont partis se balader,
on savait pas où ils étaient, et...
Elle a fait ça avec son cousin ?
C'est comme ça dans le sud.
Les mômes naissent avec 12 orteils !
Qu'est-ce que tu fous là ?
Rien, je suis juste là !
Donc, elle est allée faire cette
balade avec lui,
et quand elle est rentrée,
c'était plus la même.
Elle sentait,
le poisson avarié !
Après ça, il m'a été impossible,
de la toucher pendant des semaines.
J'ai pas pu toucher Linda
pendant 5 mois.
Linda ?
La jolie Linda ?
J'ai fait le con, un soir.
A Atlantic City, j'ai fait une virée
avec mon batteur.
On est allé dans un club,
et une des danseuses a fait son show
sur mes genoux.
Je sais, c'est moche !
Mais mes potes,
cette fille passait ses jambes,
derrière sa tête, une souplesse
incroyable, on aurait dit
une sorte de bretzel !
Sans blague ?
Désolé, continue.
Après ça, je me suis senti
tellement coupable,
que j'ai fait un blocage avec elle,
pourtant j'ai tout essayé,
je l'ai même imaginée en
strip-teaseuse,
mais rien n'a marché.
T'as pas pu bander pendant 5 mois ?
Je pose juste une question.
Qu'est-ce qui nous arrive ?
Un cousin, une strip-teaseuse,
Autrefois, on ne se cachait
absolument rien.
On se racontait tout
dans les moindres détails.
On se posait, et on parlait.
On comparait les seins
de nos copines.
Leurs jolis seins palpitants !
On s'est dit notre découverte,
du grand mystère,
le Paradis !
Lisa Fetner.
Cette sacrée Lisa Fetner !
C'est qui Lisa Fetner ?
Elle m'a dépucelé.
Moi aussi.
Lui, le premier.
Et il a fait l'article pour nous.
Je n'ai jamais parlé de vous.
Tu parles !
Vous lui plaisiez, c'est tout.
Mais tu l'as eue avant.
Je l'ai jamais eue.
Quoi ?
Comment ça ?
J'ai jamais couché avec elle.
Alors vous faisiez quoi ?
Je me réservais,
pour Brenda Nichols.
Brenda Nichols ?
C'était la bombe du lycée ?
On l'appelait "la guenon",
tellement elle était poilue !
Elle connaissait
"Ode sur une urne grecque" par coeur.
Keats.
Qui ?
Elle me l'a récité, vers après vers,
et m'a appris à le ressentir,
à comprendre.
Quoi donc ?
La beauté.
Quoi d'autre ?
Enfoiré !
Tu passais tout ton temps
avec Lisa Fetner,
et t'en pinçais pour la guenon ?
Je t'emmerde, petit con !
Colle-moi la police au cul
pendant que tu y es !
Bordel !
C'est pas juste !
Vous avez plein de trucs en commun.
C'est vrai,
moi je partage rien avec personne,
j'ai pas un seul copain sur
cette terre !
Bien sûr que si.
Qu'est-ce que t'en sais ?
De toute façon, tu m'aimes pas !
Je peux essayer.
Vraiment ?
Allez viens, approche !
Gardez la caisse,
je prendrai un taxi.
Je le sens mal.
Il a raison, n'y va pas !
Quelle journée ! Quelle soirée !
Vous êtes de sacrés mecs !
Vaut mieux qu'il dorme chez toi.
A demain au train ?
Ça fait une paie que j'ai pas passé
une nuit chez un pote !
Je m'étais planté sur toi, mec.
T'es vraiment cool,
et tu es mon héros.
Wagon fumeurs, d'accord ?
Bonne nuit.
Appelez-moi un de ces jours.
Je suis dans l'annuaire.
J'allais me mettre sur liste rouge,
mais j'ai pensé,
comment on va me trouver ?
Ouais, je suis plus le même mec !
Plus du tout le même !
Pourvu que ça dure !
Grimpe en voiture !
Ouais, j'arrive.
Bouge-toi !
Où est ta femme ?
Où elle est ?
Beth ?
Je parie qu'il t'a rien dit !
Et je sais pourquoi.
Il lâche pas la proie pour l'ombre.
Il ne prend aucun risque.
Beth ?
Où est-elle ?
Comment t'as pu me faire ça ?
Commence par me lâcher !
Viens par ici.
Je veux te montrer un truc.
Beth m'a quitté.
Il y a 5 mois.
Avec les enfants.
Ca faisait longtemps
que ça gazait plus.
Tu permets que je m'asseye ?
J'ai un mal de chien à l'épaule
que tu m'as gentiment déboîtée.
Tu vis tout seul ici ?
Ca fait 5 mois
que tu baises ma femme ?
Je ne l'ai pas baisée.
Tu fais quoi avec elle ?
Du jogging.
Quoi ?
Un matin après le départ de Beth,
j'ai été faire un jogging,
et j'ai pleuré.
Phoebe était avec moi,
et je lui ai tout dit.
On s'est trouvé beaucoup
de choses en commun.
Incroyable !
Le lendemain,
on s'est embrassés.
Je l'ai prise dans mes bras,
elle ne m'a pas repoussé.
C'est alors que j'en suis
tombé amoureux.
C'est pas possible.
T'as quoi en commun
avec ma femme ?
On t'a perdu.
Elle vient de le réaliser.
Moi, je le savais déjà.
Vois-tu,
depuis longtemps, tu n'es plus
que l'ombre de toi même.
Mais de quoi tu parles ?
Tu le sais très bien !
Je lui ai dit de ne pas te quitter,
seulement,
je n'étais pas sincère.
J'ai pas besoin de ton aide,
c'est pas un looser de ton espèce
qui va me faire la morale !
C'est quoi, ça ?
Quoi ?
Cette arme sur ton bureau ?
C'est un revolver.
Tu t'entraînes sur des canettes ?
Des souris ?
J'ai été agressé un soir
en sortant de la clinique,
alors je me suis paré.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
T'es seul, t'auras jamais ma femme,
c'est mieux que je le garde.
Tu veux en faire quoi ?
Rien du tout,
je déteste les armes.
Mais il me paraît prudent de...
Ne crains rien.
Je ne pense pas au suicide.
C'est sûr ?
Certain.
Je préfère ça.
Merci de t'en préoccuper.
T'aurais pas dû l'embrasser,
même si t'en avais envie.
T'aurais pas dû au nom
de notre amitié.
Quand on voit un copain déraper,
il faut d'abord lui tendre la main.
T'as quelque chose à...
Les alcools sont dans le salon.
Je voulais grignoter un morceau.
J'ai pas confiance, mon pote.
Frappe ta balle !
On ne joue pas la finale du Masters !
Je ne m'étais jamais senti
aussi ridicule.
Tous avec nos petites notes !
De mon temps on buvait, et
personne n'en faisait tout un plat.
Que veux-tu papa,
ce n'est certainement pas moi
qui vous aurait invités !
Non que ça ne me fasse pas plaisir
de vous voir. Au contraire.
Frappe ta balle !
Et voilà !
On dit parfois que c'est génétique.
Quoi donc ?
Je ne veux pas
que tu te sentes fautif.
De quoi ?
Il est le seul fautif, il mène une vie
de barreau de chaise.
On dit "bâton", je crois.
Quoi ?
Une vie de bâton de chaise.
A quoi faisais-tu allusion ?
A l'alcoolisme.
Et alors ?
J'ai parfois entendu dire que
c'est héréditaire.
Ça vient pas de moi.
Ni de moi !
Dommage !
T'as plié le bras droit,
relevé la tête trop tôt,
et bougé les hanches.
Je sais.
Tu oublies un de tes oncles.
Il avait une fameuse descente !
Un jour à l'arrêt du bus, il était
nu sous son imperméable,
nu comme un ver !
Et tu sais quoi ?
Il a ouvert son imper devant un
groupe de majorettes !
C'est des racontars !
Tu veux parler d'hérédité ?
Et tes pilules que tu avales
comme des bonbons ?
- Ne commencez pas !
- Je suis un cas médical.
Même le docteur le dit !
Les nerfs !
- J'ai une maladie chronique.
- On a tous nos nerfs.
Il s'écoute trop, c'est ce qu'il
a hérité de toi.
Chez toi, vous êtes tous nés avec
une cuiller d'argent dans la bouche.
Chez moi, personne ne va en
clinique psychiatrique.
Papa !
C'était pas une clinique, mais un
centre de remise en forme !
Nous on bossait,
tes parents t'ont pourrie,
et tu l'as pourri.
Il est aussi écervelé que toi.
Il fait du mieux qu'il peut !
Et pour un garçon qui a un problème
d'alcool, il s'en sort très bien !
Je ne retrouve pas cette balle !
"Le prince et l'héritier."
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Rien.
Raconte-moi.
Ça va pas te plaire.
Dis toujours.
Tu as attisé ma curiosité,
raconte-moi.
Fonder tous nos espoirs en toi...
Eh bien ?
Ce fut notre erreur.
Pourquoi ça ?
Les rois des temps anciens,
plaçaient leur héritier sur le trône,
et s'assuraient une descendance,
pour qu'un cadet puisse remplacer
un aîné défaillant.
Ta mère sait de quoi je parle.
Elle était trop fragile.
A ta naissance, elle a failli se jeter
par la fenêtre.
J'ai pas couru le risque
d'une seconde grossesse.
Si je l'avais fait, peut-être que ton
frère aurait su mener sa barque.
Et fait notre fierté.
C'est toi qui as insisté !
J'ai l'impression,
qu'on est totalement étrangers
l'un à l'autre.
Prends des cours avec un pro.
Travaille tes coups d'approche.
Je ne pense pas que ce soit fichu
entre nous.
Je n'ai rien à voir avec mon père.
Tu ne t'es pas emballée un peu vite ?
Je ne savais pas que mon vieux
copain embrassait si bien.
Mais c'est un type bien.
Je comprends que tu te sois
tournée vers lui.
C'était pas un baiser torride.
Et ce n'était pas Stuart.
C'est une tout autre personne.
Un être irréel,
pour l'instant du moins.
Je crois que j'aurai du mal à me
recaser dans mon état.
Je ne savais pas trop quoi décider
quand je l'ai su.
Tu es enceinte ?
Quand comptais-tu me le dire ?
Si je n'étais pas venu, tu...
C'est pour lui que je t'ai quitté.
Pour vivre pleinement ma grossesse.
En profiter à fond.
Phoebe, c'est merveilleux !
Je ne peux pas prendre la charge
de deux enfants.
Laisse-moi une chance !
S'il te plaît !
Où vas-tu ?
Ne pars pas !
Tu devrais te reposer.
Prends davantage soin de toi.
Un baiser ?
C'est tout ?
Tout ce foin pour un baiser ?
On peut se concentrer
sur le vrai problème ?
On va pas à flipper parce qu'il
est pas chez lui !
C'est vrai, il doit être en ville.
Sa voiture est au garage.
Il fait une balade.
Ça fait 3 heures qu'il a disparu.
Il fait une longue promenade,
pas de quoi flipper !
Personne ne sait où il est.
Il a mon revolver.
Comment a-t-il pu
se procurer une arme ?
On n'a pas besoin de leçons,
tout est de votre faute !
On vous a casqué 200 dollars
pour rien,
Vous avez eu votre diplôme
dans une pochette surprise ?
Ne me parlez pas sur ce ton.
J'ai un patient
entre la vie et la mort !
Je suis à bout de nerfs !
Il est à bout de nerfs !
Fantastique !
Je vous conseille de le retrouver
très vite,
car ce soir,
le suicide est dans l'air.
Qu'est-ce qu'il a dit ?
Excusez-moi,
je me suis mal exprimé.
Oubliez ces paroles malheureuses.
J'ai une méthode,
je peux vous aider à distance.
C'est un cauchemar !
Qu'est-ce qu'il a dit ?
Des conneries !
Excuse-moi, c'est toi
qui a engagé ce mec !
Il prétend nous aider à distance !
J'y peux rien,
s'il a piqué mon flingue !
Tu avais besoin d'essayer
de baiser sa femme ?
Ca n'a aucun rapport
avec cette séance.
A d'autres !
C'est à cause de ça que t'as eu
cette idée débile.
De quoi tu parles ?
Tu sais quoi ?
T'as mis en scène ce procès idiot.
De quel droit peut-on juger ?
Même s'il y avait
une part d'inconscient.
On va le chercher rue après rue.
Tu parles !
Tu fais que tourner en rond !
Laisse-moi le volant !
Arrêtez la caisse !
Mike est là !
Où ?
Là !
Tu l'as déjà vu comme ça ?
Il est bourré.
Hey, Mikey !
Salut, vieux.
Voilà l'équipe !
On se fait un petit échauffement ?
Pas maintenant,
on était inquiets pour toi.
Stuart a perdu son arme.
Tu l'as pas, par hasard ?
Ouais... c'est ce revolver ?
C'est ça !
L'agite pas comme ça !
- Donne-le nous !
- Pardonne-moi de t'avoir fait mal,
je me suis mal conduit,
et je le regrette sincèrement.
Rends-moi cette arme !
Je comprends, vous croyez que je
vais me faire sauter la cervelle !
C'est bien ce que vous pensez ?
J'ai retiré les six balles,
regardez.
Vous croyez que je me baladerais
avec un flingue chargé ?
Vous êtes fous ?
Vous devenez parano ?
Oui, t'as raison.
On est débiles.
On oublie ça.
Si on poussait notre cri de guerre ?
C'est bon ? Vous êtes prêts ?
On va te ramener chez toi.
T'es fatigué.
Tu te fiches de moi ?
Je pète la forme !
Allez, venez !
Pour qui on court ?
Pour son équipe !
Comment on gagne ?
Tous ensemble !
Jusqu'où peut-on aller ?
Dites-le !
Jusqu'au bout !
Exactement !
Jusqu'à ce qu'on crève !
Si on te raccompagnait ?
Qu'en dis-tu ?
Qu'est-ce que je vais faire...
chez moi ?
Je suis garé à côté.
Très bien !
Débrouille-toi tout seul !
Il rentrera à pieds.
Attendez !
J'ai un truc marrant.
Cinq petites balles qui s'en vont,
et il en reste une.
Qui rentre à la maison ?
Tu nous fais quoi ?
Il est tôt,
je veux pas rentrer.
Vous voulez pas faire
un 100 mètres ?
Je vous donne le départ !
Désolé, faux départ !
Je vais m'échauffer un peu.
Arrête, tu vas te blesser !
Rabat-joie !
Fais pas ci !... Fais pas ça !
Reviens !
On regrette
tout ce qui s'est passé !
C'était un très mauvais plan,
on est vraiment désolés.
On est désolés !
Quels faux-derches !
Quel gâchis !
T'es viré, mon pote.
Pas de faux derches
dans mon équipe.
Toi, dans mon équipe ?
Autant me tirer une balle dans le pied.
J'ai eu chaud.
Michael, laisse-moi t'aider !
Je sais où on peut te soigner.
Ta gueule !
T'as embrassé ma femme
derrière mon dos.
Tu mériterais que je t'explose
les burnes !
Ou que je te bute.
Qu'est-ce que t'en dis ?
Ça suffit maintenant !
Ça suffit !
T'es complètement barré !
Je t'emmerde !
Fous le camp !
On peut pas le laisser !
Pourquoi pas ?
Toute l'équipe s'égare !
C'est pas comme ça qu'on gagne !
Il est devenu fou !
Arrête ça, merde !
C'est quoi, ton problème ?
Laissez tomber, on se casse !
Arrête !... T'es un pote,
je t'en prie, arrête !
Je vais courir avec toi,
dans la bonne direction.
Mais donne-moi ce revolver.
Pourquoi tu chiales ?
On veut pas
que tu coures de risques !
Vous voulez jamais
courir de risques !
Vous savez ce que ça me donne
envie de faire ?
Déconne pas !
Me faire sauter le caisson !
T'es timbré !
Ca fait 5 balles.
Arrête ton cirque maintenant !
Ça sert à rien,
c'est un malade mental !
J'ai la rage.
J'ai la rage de vivre.
Vous l'avez plus !
Vous tous !
Vous l'avez jamais eue.
Ça pouvait pas coller avec moi !
Vous vous entravez sans arrêt !
Regardez-vous en face !
Vous sortez votre petite poubelle,
et dites la prière du soir !
Je bois trop ?
Je vous emmerde !
J'aime mieux mon mode de vie.
Si j'étais comme vous, vous savez
ce que je ferais ?
Faut que je vous montre un truc !
Crétins !
Bande de morts vivants !
Morts avant d'avoir vécu !
Seigneur, sauve-moi des ténèbres,
montre-moi la lumière !
Partez pas !
Je vais vous donner
encore une chance.
Vous voulez rester dans l'équipe ?
Je vais vous dire quoi faire.
Je vais vous ouvrir la voie.
Hey, revenez ici !
Je vous parle !
Bande d'enfoirés, je vous parle !
Où vous allez ?
Me laissez pas !
Revenez, bordel !
Docteur Trent ?
Oui.
Le respirateur artificiel a lâché,
il y a 20 minutes.
Je suis désolé.
Moi aussi.
Vous êtes de la famille ?
Je suis le gars que vous n'êtes
jamais venu assister.
Pardonnez-moi.
En quoi puis-je vous être utile ?
C'est à lui que j'aurais aimé parler.
Pardon ?
Il aurait peut-être pu m'éclairer.
Me dire ce qui pousse
à de telles extrémités.
Et si on en réchappe,
comment trouver la façon,
de se reconstruire?
Vous savez,
l'alcoolisme cache toujours
un mal être.
C'est ce que j'ai essayé de leur
faire comprendre.
Il faut un avoir but dans la vie.
Savoir gagner de nouvelles choses,
une nouvelle course,
un nouvel amour, un voyage,
un endroit inconnu.
J'avais hâte de me lever,
l'avenir semblait radieux.
Avec le temps, tout a changé.
L'avenir m'a paru sombre.
Il s'est rétréci, et il est devenu...
...gris.
J'aime le bleu de l'océan.
Après quelques verres, plus de gris.
J'avais la pêche, et autrefois
mes amis appréciaient.
Une vie sans piment,
une petite vie rangée,
toute étriquée,
ça me fout le cafard.
Je sais que c'est le quotidien.
Le quotidien ordinaire,
est trop banal à mon goût.
Je fonctionne ainsi depuis
si longtemps que si j'arrêtais,
je ne saurais plus,
qui je suis.
Bonjour.
J'ai noté mon adresse.
J'entre dans le service du Dr Trent,
6ème étage, vue sur cour,
pas de mini bar,
pas exactement un club de vacances.
Les visites sont interdites
les 15 premiers jours.
Mais ensuite,
si tu passes dans le secteur.
Je viendrai.
Si tu supportes.
Tu es vraiment
une femme merveilleuse.
Si le bébé tient de toi,
je ne me fais pas de souci.
C'est le mieux qu'on puisse espérer.
Pour l'instant.
Le train de 8h05 pour
Manhattan entre en gare.
Dégage !
Tout le monde en voiture !
On pensait que c'était fichu.
A cause de ses chaussures,
de son âge.
Il a retrouvé sa femme.
Il a gagné !
Pour qui on court ?
Pour son équipe.
Comment on gagne?
Tous ensemble.
Jusqu'où peut-on aller ?
Répondez !
Jusqu'au bout.
Exactement...
jusqu'à ce qu'on crève!